Speaker 1: Here is something just
unbelievable that this is I don't even.
Donald J. Trump, what do you think
of that? Sounds like an insult,
right? Sounds like something that detractors
of Trump would say. Greg Steube, a Republican
congressman who has made the decision
against the wishes of Florida Republicans
to come out and endorse Trump, now went on
Newsmax his big announcement, and he says,
I am proud to endorse Donald Trump.
Speaker 3: Yeah, and Rob, I want to
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to talk about this on your show. And I'm
happy and honored to endorse Donald J. Trump.
Speaker 1: This is this is such a backfire in
so many ways. So let me give you the back story of
what's going on here. NBC News article. Ron, this
is from six days ago. Ron DeSantis his team tries
to stop Florida Republicans from endorsing Trump.
The governor's team has reached out to at least
six Florida congressional Republicans over the
past week trying to stop the bleeding. The idea
here is as follows DeSantis hasn't announced yet.
He may announce at some point over the next 3 to
4 months is. But for some reason, July keeps being
talked about. Okay, If a bunch of these Florida
Republicans jump out and endorse Trump right now,
it's not great for DeSantis. DeSantis is going
to want to build his base of support with
endorsements, presumably starting with Florida
Republicans. Greg Steube decided, I'm going to
take a stand. I'm going to get in Trump's good
graces. I'm going to try to get an attaboy from
Trump. So I'm going to proudly go on Newsmax
and announce that I am indeed endorsing Trump.
And then you get his name wrong.
And not only do you get it wrong,
you use an insulting term. TRUMP Yeah.
Speaker 3: And Rob, I want to thank
you for giving me the opportunity to
talk about this on your show. And I'm
happy and honored to endorse Donald J. Trump.
Speaker 1: This is your big moment to get on
Trump's good side to try to get attention. Barely
anyone cares what Greg Steube ever says. And you
go out there and you call him a chump. Now, he
also attacked Ron DeSantis, and this is where it
starts to get a little bit more interesting beyond
just the cartoonish nature of Trump. The attacks
on DeSantis are also starting to be coordinated.
Speaker 4: That is one thing that I hear from
a lot of people that I know. I've got a
lot of friends in Florida, and they say
that when the Sanders talks about, you know,
when they think this thing is going to run,
they're mortified because they don't
want to lose him in the Sunshine State.
Speaker 3: Yeah, it's he hasn't even been
elected reelected for six months. And while
we're in legislative session right now and
the state legislature is doing their business,
he's in South Carolina and Iowa. I think he's up
here in Washington tomorrow meeting with people
where his focus should be in Florida. Floridians
want him to be focused on Florida. That's what
he signed up for his job for reelection to do.
Speaker 1: So this is telegraphing and predicting
what is going to be a big line of attack from anti
de Santos Republicans. They showed us these cards.
They showed us that this was the hand they were
going to be playing even before the election.
We had clips of Kerry Lake and Marjorie Taylor
GREENE, who, by the way, want to be Trump's VP,
saying DeSantis needs to do his work for the
people of Florida. DeSantis has been reelected
to be the governor. DeSantis should commit to
serving the full term, which DeSantis opted not
to do during his debate in the 2022 midterms. So
this is going to be a line of attack. This is a
guy who should be doing what he told Floridians
he was going to do. He is disloyal or he is some
way doing the wrong thing by not staying and
serving his term. This is going to be a line
of attack, it's abundantly clear. Will DeSantis
announce? I don't know. We'll know very soon.